there's so much strangeness behind the
scenes in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
that even its own actors couldn't
explain and no surprisingly Doctor
Strange didn't make this list from
unfathomable butt Prosthetics to kissing
all of your castmates come take every
MCU strange turn with us number one up
first is perhaps the strangest rumor
flying around the MCU and we only have
one question who had them but one of us
has a fake ass in their suit really
thanks to Tom Holland's inability to
keep anything secret we now know one
Spider-Man actor on the set of no way
home required a little support from
behind none of them will admit too for
obvious reasons but we can only guess
the one who hasn't said anything is the
guilty party here Toby you are the
perfect Spider-Man just the way you are
Prosthetics or not number two wouldn't
it be a little awkward bringing a
wedding gift to a funeral I was told it
was a wedding
good thing none of the cast of Avengers
endgame did because when they showed up
for Tony's wedding they were shocked to
find out their attire was for his
funeral it was so strange for some of
the cast as they couldn't even figure
out what the occasion was until the
director started the scene but being
that Robert Downey Jr wasn't there they
were able to put two and two together
number three we couldn't imagine how
weird it would have felt for Robert to
finish his lengthy time as Iron Man with
the stunning snap at the end of end game
it was actually filmed right next door
to where he had his very first screen
test for the first Iron Man movie very
strange how you go so far in a role only
to end literally at the beginning number
four another strange way of dealing with
a high strung environment is to just
have all the cast kiss each other after
takes things got very intimate for the
cast of age Voltron on set and luckily
we were graced with behind the scenes
video of most of the instances the mono
must have spread faster than Ultron
around the set number five not
surprising that the biggest Avengers
filmed to date would not give actual
scripts to its actors given that there
were plenty of spoilers floating around
for Infinity War the Russo brothers were
not chancing any for end game wait till
you see this next one everybody talks
so no full scripts were given to any of
the cast and Holland only received his
lines it would have been strange to not
know who you were talking to until
stepping on set we could only imagine
poor Holland had to improvise his line
choices a lot number six you'd think
casting directors would take into
consideration as to whether or not the
main actress is able to work alongside
their sidekick unfortunately when they
cast Brie Larson for the role of Captain
Marvel they did not consider if she was
allergic to cats being revealed after
the fact they decided to spend more of
the budget on making the feline CGI
number seven good thing dancing wasn't
the only way to defeat Thanos because
the cast of infinity War really couldn't
do it a little music video sesh was
coordinated by some of the gas but let's
just say that some of them were really
not about it Anthony Mackey could at
least disclose that someone was doing
something right saying we shot half of
it and then people realized how bad they
were at dancing and we couldn't get
anyone else to dance Mark Ruffalo
dancing is a spectacle that everyone
should behold once in their life number
eight sometimes you gotta relieve a
little stress and prank some of your
co-stars Paul Rudd was busy filming
Ant-Man and infinity War simultaneously
so what makes all the stress better well
obviously getting pranked by Anthony
Mackey of course the real strange part
about this is the fact that Anthony
would go out of his way to do the
undisclosed pranks taking time out of
his own break to walk over to the
Ant-Man set and raise Havoc number nine
this one's a creepy Peter tingle to the
we were surprised to learn that when
Peter's arm hair stands up on his arm at
the beginning of infinity war that no
CGI was involved no they didn't tie
strings to each of his arm hairs and
pulled them up at exactly the same time
they just had someone off camera
strangely blowing on Tom's ear to make
the hair raise up we don't think we
could have kept a straight face there
number 10. Paul Bettany has seen a lot
of strange things but nothing like the
trailer town of infinity War he recalls
filming his first scene and being shown
to his trailer which was stuck somewhere
in the hundreds of trailers parked at
the studio not only is this super
unusual to have in even a blockbuster
production but it's so abnormal for an
MCU movie
number 11 some teenagers leave high
school and never come back and
unfortunately for Holland he was happy
to have left before but was now called
back for homecoming director John Watts
thought it'd be a great idea to send Tom
back to high school undercover at the
Bronx High School of Science but Tallinn
took his strange opportunity to begin
his string of giving out Secrets he told
quite literally everyone that he was
playing Spider-Man if I'm actually
Spiderman
you're nuts number 12 Holland was really
subjected to a lot of strange activity
and in this case it was the spider thong
that caused him a lot of upset to make
sure the outfit fit tightly no wonder
clothes were needed however you still
gotta make sure nothing is showing so a
thong seemed to do the trick number 13.
another unusual prank for a quite
unusual character as part of his
initiation into the MCU Tom needed a
warm welcome on the set of homecoming so
what did the crew do you for him they
replaced his chair on set with the
toilet we aren't sure if it was
functioning or not but if it was the
joke is on them he doesn't need to walk
around for the bathroom anymore number
14 for Captain America humor is very
conservative and held back but for Chris
Evans he finds the darkest of humor in
all places with all the sadness and
laying his long-lost love Peggy to rest
in Civil War Chris found this an
opportunity to send Haley Atwell a pit
from the set captioning you look pretty
hot when you're old and dead very
strange humor from America's hero number
15 when your character is supposed to be
eight foot tall You Gotta Wear antennas
for CGI work makes sense James Spader's
performance caused a lot of confusion
for the actors specifically for
Elizabeth Olsen who just couldn't focus
on the antennae because of Spader's
amazing performance she recalled The
Experience being extremely strange and
having to ignore such a dominant acting
performance on set number 16. did Chris
Pratt really get jealous over a CGI
character not so much the CGI but of the
little baby Groot statue director James
Gunn created as a stand-in for the cast
this thing was so cute that Pratt
started feeling a little upstaged by it
Gunn explained we just had this adorable
little statue standing there and we'd
get in the scene and all this stuff
would be going on and the cast would be
acting their thoughts on all of a sudden
Chris Pratt would look over at Baby
Groot and go damn it he's gonna steal
the whole movie number 17 sometimes
mocap suits can make things a little
strange on set for the other characters
with rocket being a full CGI character
that he still needed someone in a mocap
suit to interact with everyone and
seeing a Tall Sean gun get pet by the
others is strangely uncomfortable but
we're happy they went with a fuzzy
raccoon in the end number 18 yes the
Shawarma end credit scene was quite
strange and unexpected for a superhero
movie but for this group of Misfits it
became iconic but what was the oddest
aspect about this situation it was the
very subtle fact that Captain America
was really not eating like the rest this
was actually because they had shot the
scene months after shooting ended and
Chris Evans had made commitments to grow
a mustache for snow piercer talk about a
good cover-up number 19 Robert Downey Jr
was one hungry Tony on the set of Iron
Man and pretty much every MCU movie he
was in it's not a weird occurrence to
bring some snacks to set but eating them
during takes definitely strange when
you're offering a snack to your scene
Partners in an actual take honestly
that's just a real ballsy Downey Jr move
on his part number 20 the Genesis of the
MCU Iron Man didn't even have a script
when they started filming quite a
strange request to make of the actors
considering they'd have no lines to
prepare it seemed like Robert adapted to
it pretty well but for Jeff Bridges he
said we would show up for Big scenes
every day and we wouldn't know what we
were going to say maybe we'll never know
which Spidey needed some extra padding
but that doesn't outshine the fact that
many of these MCU Heroes went a little
crazy on set these strange experiences
definitely seem to cross over on screen
making for some hilariously awkward
moments what was your favorite strange
moment on the set of the MCU let us know
in the comments